I have four pounds of mushrooms right
here so I'm gonna be here for a minute
wait there's a food processor yes I
would love to use the food processor
please
[Music]
hey what's up my name is Tui and welcome
to making it big the show where I turn
your favorite food and make it giant I
have a very special guest with me here
today Mr Ben Hundreds
way hi
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having me I'm really nervous about
this challenge because I mean by the
looks of the bamboo steamer I kind of
know what you're gonna challenge me to
but I don't know what kind so let's see
of course it's a soup dumpling the
hardest one to make you really think so
yes absolutely soup dumplings it's
incredibly difficult to make just this
size I really wanted to challenge you
today how big do you want me to make
this I want big like how big like I want
to carry it like this big oh you want to
like hug it yeah that's a really big
challenge dude you couldn't just like
challenge me to make like a gyoza or
something no I could have but I didn't
want to I accept your challenge I will
make a giant soup dumpling let's get
started
for soup dumplings we need to make soup
so I'm going to be using an instant pot
for this this is my chicken stock that's
going to go in then adding some flavor
to it so soy sauce some ginger garlic
green onions and this is a little cheat
code this is ham it's going to add some
nice flavor to the broth without having
to add some actual bones into it give
this a nice little stir this is probably
the easiest part of the soup dumpling so
The Dumpling is shaped like a purse
which I think is really cute that's a
cute purse can you edit a purse a
dumpling purse for me and the more
pleats that you have at the top that
means whoever's making your dumpling is
very skilled so today I'm gonna try my
best to make as many pleats as possible
maybe like a hundred maybe less we'll
see this looks like it's going to be
done so I'm going to strain it and then
add my gelatin
this smells so good so so good I think
it's the ham and the soy that is giving
this really Savory smell I wish I could
drink this right now but I have to bloom
my gelatin this is actually not the
traditional way of making it I'm using
gelatin because I'm making a big giant
dumpling so I don't want to risk it not
setting and I also can't just add this
gelatin right into the hot water I have
to bloom it with cold water because hot
water is going to kill the gelatin
meaning it's not going to help it Bloom
then I'm gonna strain it look at that
color you can tell just by looking at it
that it has so much flavor pour this
right into my sheet tray this is going
to take four hours so in the meantime
I'm going to make my dough
usually dumpling dough is really easy to
make I usually use all-purpose flour but
since this is a bit big giant dumpling
I'm going to use bread flour and cake
flour instead bread flour has more
gluten so I feel like it has more
structure to hold the dumpling better
five and a half cups of bread flour and
then cake flour will keep it tender a
little salt give it all a whisk then I
have hot water so the bread flour I'm
just kind of taking an educated guess
I'm not sure how this is going to turn
out I hope that it will hold up like I
thought it would but
we'll see okay time to get messy so my
first time ever having soup dumplings
was here in America I don't think
there's any soup dumplings in Vietnam
maybe now since it's so popular and the
first time I had a soup dumpling I
burned my mouth because I just didn't
know what to expect but the flavor it
was insane I've never had anything
juicier and I was hooked I'm gonna put
it out on the table and then knead it
until it turns smooth so usually when I
make dumplings the dough is probably
half this size and it makes like 50
dumplings but this is a dough for one
this is probably gonna take me a hot
minute my arms are actually feeling
really good I'm feeling strong if you
hate the gym get in the kitchen so in
culinary school making dough we actually
had to fight over
the mixer there were only like four to a
class so most of us had to do this by
hand I'm getting flashbacks
this dough feels pretty good all I need
to do is uh check
yep and it bounces back so it's ready
my baby's gonna rest for 30 minutes
this is
five pounds of pork that's a lot of meat
for one dumpling so let's get to it I
have some scallions here so for the
scallions I'm using both the whites and
the greens it both offers a really nice
texture to the filling I love the smell
of just raw green onions and this goes
right into the pork then I have some
baby Portobellos here so I'm just going
to mince up
oh I'm just kidding okay this is a
product of one mushroom I have four
pounds of mushrooms right here so I'm
gonna be here for a minute
[Music]
wait there's a food processor yes I
would love to use the food processor
please
okay four pounds of minced baby
portobello mushrooms courtesy of my
bestie the food processor later I'm
gonna add it straight into the meat and
I love mushrooms because it has a
natural Umami flavor to it and it has a
meaty texture and then for my seasoning
I'm going to add in soy sauce xiaoxing
wine a little bit of sesame oil salt and
white pepper about like a full bulb of
garlic here I'm just going to grate this
is pretty much the amount of garlic I
put in my regular dumpling filling
anyways because I love garlic Ben is a
foodie so I really hope that he likes
garlic but if he doesn't then I guess
I'll have a really big dumpling to
myself and then now I'm gonna grate some
ginger it's great in Dumplings great and
dumpling sauce what is a dumpling
without some ginger this is my favorite
part time to mix it all together all of
this is filling for just one dumpling
like this is actually kind of insane and
I'm kind of concerned if it's actually
gonna cook all the way through but hey
that's what good pork dumpling filling
sounds like
okay I'm kind of avoiding this because
this is the moment of truth it's
assembly time meaning you have to roll
the dough out put this bad boy in the
dough and then try to pleat
now I have all of my components and I'm
ready to assemble I actually had to take
this part out this right here the
bottom of this one out this is too
shallow for the big dumpling to sit in
so this gives it a nice deep wall so it
can hold up the big dumpling I'm going
to line this first I have napa cabbage
here I'm going to just line the bottom
and the sides so The Dumpling doesn't
stick I'm just
kind of working with hopes and dreams
over here okay I'm gonna dust my Surface
so my dough doesn't stick roll out my
dough I'm Gonna Roll this out into a
nice
thin circle I thought this dough was
going to be harder to roll out but it's
actually not because it's very stretchy
very hydrated I'm gonna measure this 18
inches in diameter time to transfer this
dough into
[Music]
okay so far so good now I'm gonna add
the spilling man this smells so good
this is just an insane amount of filling
for one dumpling I really really hope
that all of this pork gets cooked and I
hope that my dough doesn't fall apart on
me some way somehow this is a tricky one
okay all my meat is in so I'm making a
little well in my meat mixture so I can
put the soup into the soup dumpling this
is gelatin soup and this is actually how
they put the soup into the soup dumpling
look at that
well I love it
brushing some water onto my dumpling
wrapper so when I start to pleat it it
can stick together I'm gonna start right
here because it kind of looks like a
little pleat right here already so I'm
just gonna grab so the more pleats means
the more skilled let's see if I can get
a hundred I'm on my fifth plate just
trying to be as gentle as possible the
small pleats aren't really working out
for me so I think I might just I gotta
just do the bigger pleats I didn't get a
hundred pleats I got about like 14 not
skilled but not as
as bad as I thought it would be there's
a little bit of extra dough here I'm
just gonna snip it off see Aesthetics
okay this looks good fold this back I
really really hope this works no going
back now
yeah I'm gonna put the basket in this I
have boiling water ready for me get this
bad boy up here and I'm gonna let this
Steam for two hours
so while my dumpling is steaming away
I'm going to start on my sauce I have
some ginger right here I'm just gonna
cut into thin slices perfect the ginger
really gives the sauce a nice Aroma and
just Flavor now I have black vinegar and
soy sauce here I like to add a little
bit more black vinegar than soy sauce
usually people like to do equal parts
but I love my sauce to be
very acidic and I'm just going to
measure it with my heart this reminds me
of two shots of vodka
and then I have a little bit of chili
flakes here this is not just some
regular old chili flakes this is Thai
chili chili flakes I'm gonna let this
sit so the flavors can start to develop
and marry with each other that's it
two hours later
dude Ben is gonna freak out this looks
really good let's plate this and get it
ready for Ben
okay my heart is actually racing because
I cannot wait to show Ben this Ben I
have something for you
yeah welcome back wow are you ready I
don't know if I am
oh my God you read the giant soup don't
blink compared to
wow how did you do this it's so good so
much trial and error I think this has to
be the most challenging challenge yet so
this is a total of five pounds of meat
okay four pounds of mushrooms in the
filling wow and the dough by itself is
three pounds I got us some boba straw I
thought it would be fun for us to kind
of just drink the soup sure let's do it
thoughts I love it okay should we dig
into this yes yes we should the only way
to go about this is to cut it like a
cake sure would this be considered like
a meat pie now yeah
insane okay I Loki was worried that it
might not be cooked through
it's perfect yes so this is just a
regular dumping sauce soy sauce black
vinegar Ginger and then we have some
chili oil over there great
wow it tastes like a soup dumpling
perfect it checks out almost all the
boxes I mean the biggest difference
between this and a small one is when you
bought into a small one it explodes in
your mouth right and like half the time
you might even burn your mouth when you
eat a soup right so besides that it's
pretty spot on that's because you just
don't got a big enough mouth yeah maybe
can you imagine if I would have picked
it up but I think I checked off all of
the boxes to be honest okay I'll give it
to you thank you thank you well this has
been really fun thank you so much for
challenging me I can officially say that
I made a big soup dumpling in the
comments down below let me know what I
should make big next
[Music]
thank you